back when the major show was on uh
Thursday and everything else was on mug
Club I think they were called Crowder
closes which is a silly name I don't
know what we call them now uh but uh I
have a moment of your time and you can
comment if you want me to do it on
Thursday toward the end uh or like this
today I want to talk about a a topic
that just I've been hearing a lot lately
or I guess seeing on the Instagram feed
which by the way is toxic it's likely
the worst thing for your mind that's why
we always tell you this is just a show
tune in and tune out check the
references you don't want to be
scrolling every day for a dopamine hit
every 35 seconds but I hear this a lot
and I don't know that I agree with it
and maybe I'm wrong you hear people say
hey you can't love anyone else until you
TR until you love yourself self love is
most important because you can't love
anybody until you love yourself um
no my opinion is no and the reason I
think it's been on my heart is I
actually think that that can be
destructive advice now look let me be
clear you shouldn't hate yourself um and
this I believe comes from a Biblical
prescription of you know if you're
forgiven by God who are you to not
forgive yourself you shouldn't hate
yourself and you should strive to uh I
don't want to say love yourself but
respect yourself to become someone
worthy of respect but to assume that you
or as a blanket statement that everybody
should automatically love themselves
that you right now watching of the
millions of you who will watch this once
this is done that you should love
yourself I don't agree with it not to
mention there's huge um societal
confusion right now of Love versus being
in love with yourself look you should
respect yourself I want to correct this
I want to be careful with my words you
should want to mold yourself into
someone worthy of your
respect but the idea that if you don't
love yourself or if you're not in love
with yourself that you can't love others
how does that make sense we hear it a
lot and not many people are argue over
that point but how does that make
sense I would much sooner believe that
someone who dislikes themselves is
capable of serving and loving others
before someone who Ador themselves to
use those extreme examples let me give
you a point let me give you an analogy
let's say a man not not a drunk driver
but a man accidentally hits a child who
walks across the road in the middle of
the night I knew someone like this uh
the child didn't die but I know that
sometimes those kinds of things happen
this person never forgave
themselves I don't know if that would
constitute self-loathing or hated
themselves but certainly had a lot of uh
had a lot of animosity towards himself
had a lot of
guilt do you believe that that
person is less capable of loving someone
else than an Instagram self-infatuated
model who undoubtedly loves
themselves and why are you the only
person to whom this
applies if you don't love yourself we
never hear oh if they don't love their
cousins they're incapable of loving
anyone else truly oh if if you don't
love your if you don't love your your
brother you're not capable of of loving
me oh no Jesus said something like that
that's right it wasn't always about
loving
yourself people are capable of loving
all kinds of people while disliking
others including yourself or at least
certainly certainly qualities individual
people not only is
this self-help bull crap designed uh to
keep the Feed the Beast going in your
Instagram or your Tik Tok whatever it is
it's it's it's to me it's more pervasive
and we see this a lot it's designed to
convince you that you're never wrong
that you should have no
shame now you shouldn't live in shame
you shouldn't live in regret and as
someone who believes in God that that is
is removed and cast as far away as you
know the eye can see once you've
repented but the idea that there should
be no sh without some kind of shame or
guilt there can be no
repentance this idea to convince you
that you should love yourself first
before you try and love anyone else that
must mean that you're never you are
always right you are priority number one
you shouldn't be ashamed and you know
what sometimes you should I know
sometimes I
should we shouldn't live in shame but
we've all done shame
things and it's not self-loathing to
want to work at
it and to want to improve yourself so
that you may potentially lift your own
veil of shame to become someone you can
truly respect and ultimately love you
can't love someone you don't respect and
here's the irony this is why I think the
the the saying the colloquialism is so
damaging how do you get there how do you
get to the point of moving past your
shame and becoming someone you respect
and can ultimately
love by loving others
first first before
Yourself by serving others first before
Yourself by esteeming others
first so the first step is not
self-love the first step is being
selfless it's loving others first
love others enough serve others
enough and only then can you truly
respect or love yourself I think we've
done it in
reverse try it that way see if it works
out better for you I'm willing to bet
that you
will okay on with the
show I want my new contract but I like
you Steven yes I like you my brother
likes you too you good to my brother I
will join Mud Club that's great Kevin
it's Keith that's great Keith I'm happy
no I'm just with you it's Kevin
are you listen yes this is what I'm
going to do for you God bless you Steven
but this is what you going to do for me
you listening Steven yes what can I do
for you H just tell me what I can do for
you it's very personal Stephen hell it's
a family model are you ready stepen I'm
ready just want to make sure you
ready
show me the Mud
Club show me the Mud Club St yeah don't
that make you feel good Sten share with
me show you the Mud Club no you can do
better that Sten I want you to say it
like you mean it brother like Ana's
coming after hey I got Fox News on the
online I want to hear he say Stephen
yeah yeah yeah no no no no no no show
you the Muk Club no not show you show me
the Muk Club show me the Muk Club yeah l
show me the mug Club yeah I need to feel
it Sten I need to feel it show me the
mug Club yell it like you mean it show
me the M Club show me the M Club you
love black queen Ste I love the black
man show me the Mud Club I love black
people Stephen I love black people who's
your Sten you're my
motherfu show me the Mud Club Steven
show me the mother
Club
congratulations We join a Mud
Club what's a mug Club shut
up remember none of this happens without
your support at mug Club if you join
lwith c.com mug Club you can sign up for
89 annually and get the entire roster
Network undercover unit mug
Club completes
[Music]
me
that's what I
[Music]
know
glad to be with you again since we did
that open I usually don't do those but
every now and then every now and then I
like it my self love no now stop it I
love you stepen I love you I love you
Kevin Andor Keith
uh as a matter of fact here before we do
the rundown now people know who's in
third just let's let's hit their music
you know who it
is in third chair when you see them you
know them you love you can follow them @
conservative twin
Keith and Kevin Hodge the Hodge twins
how are you gentlemen oh we're doing
amazing yeah yeah yeah know I love
myself I love Stephen I love you Keith
this is a weird I love white people this
is I really love white people where that
come from this invasion of the twin
snatchers now really is uh we will be
tomorrow announcing when the hot twins
your show is going to be starting on mug
club right here this very Network this
month so tomorrow we're going to have
the official announcements the date the
time and uh you guys sign up glad to
have you here uh I don't you don't get
two mugs by the way just if you sign up
you don't you still get one we can't
make those margins but we have a lot to
get to here today here's uh The Rundown
uh Feinstein obviously uh passed away
that's sad right that's not good let's
all be clear about
that
but Jamal Bowman uh we've done this in
the past you know and by the way uh if
you before we finish I'm gonna have to
do this before the
rundown because YouTube doesn't
sometimes they don't want us to do the
segment but it's the word for sure if
you see this on YouTube at any point
today head on over to rumble that's the
best place to watch anyway because we
will be doing back to the rundown Jamal
Bowman what a piece of uh part two
because he did pull the fire alarm there
in our hallowed Halls he smelled smoke
yes he did smelled something and this
is this is a bad person this is a very
very bad men uh I don't know if you guys
know this he pulled the alarm over
trying to of course avoid
uh getting through this government
spending Bill the vote so they can put
it firmly on Republicans and say look
the government shut down which really
only affects federal workers and I don't
really care also the Nobel Prize was
just awarded to some some scientists for
the MRNA injection huh so we'll be
talking about that who these people are
and I don't know we'll do we'll give you
an update how many billions of dollars
in profits these companies have made and
how many billions of dollars in well
subsidies came from you the tax you paid
and they made oh so before we get to
that what kind of punishment do you
think Jamal Bowman should should face
for pulling the fire alarm I think Keel
hauling but that's just meon Mr
traditional they're giving prison time
away to January 6 people for doing the
exact same thing in their terms they
were they were what inhibiting a a a
public I don't even know what they call
it but like a public process or some
kind of thing I'm I'm not sure on the
wordage what if you are the public
process yes yeah and your process is in
grade school you get expelled you get
expelled for pulling the fire alarm
that's true true but you can't say well
I'm I'm an idiot which is what he's
saying we'll get to it yeah that's
number two CEO Gerald Morgan good how
are you I'm doing well I can't find
words yet but you know that should
concern you it's a live show it was an
atypical week last week with the 4-Hour
debate stream we did and that that that
messed me up cuz I can't go to sleep
until 2 and we got to be up and do the
whole show and then one of the hot twins
took off his headphones so he won't be
able to hear these
clips it's it's protest yeah it's a
friendly protest all right what is
something wrong with your headphones
yeah I can't hear
you turned the knob down what
happened over there right now get out
hey hit hit the like button if you're
watching on YouTube not for this not for
this but well no no just don't just hand
him the
headphones he just handed him the he
took them off cuz he just like oh no you
can't hear cuz there are no headphones
the volume was down on the knob he just
had to turn the volume knob off have you
never encountered a volume knob Hills
what I didn't know it came with a dob I
showed you the dob it was wor did get
away oh Lord okay now I can hear
everything hear yeah you can adjust it
on your side there yeah you can go you
just spin it louder lower louder louer
oh okay okay we don't use h
phon that's because you two are joined
at the hip they go to the bathroom
together it's very entertaining uh all
right before we move on to anything else
uh this is just kind of fun we did this
on our show one time Craig Jones who's
based out of Austin choked out Alex
Jones and it's pretty much exactly what
you would
expect
okay night night oh boy here comes a
snort
watch watch
[Laughter]
what and then he immediately went in to
a rant about The Clockwork
elves I have seen the demons just I've
seen the Clockwork elvs look I don't
know what happened he just opened an
interdimensional
portal he just passed out sir I know but
I saw stuff yeah I saw I saw things that
one should never see I'm a hero
[Music]
um it's and by the way this is also why
I support show colds from the police if
learned properly it is the most peaceful
way to be incapacitated in a fight you
don't even know it's like falling asleep
at your desk and pulling the fire
alarm yeah yeah remember when you did I
don't know if you mentioned it I I don't
yeah we did it on this show the exact
same thing happened yeah we had audio
Wade down there on the floor but you did
it in a nice way I was a little worried
about the chair just in that because I'm
like oh he's going to fall out of the
chair when he passes out a little bit
but he no he h him yeah Craig Jones is a
decent guy we did it on the floor where
you were you had him kind of cradled so
he couldn't go anywhere he totally say
fine and he didn't even know by the way
don't try it at home just so you know
don't try that at home just because I
advocate it for the police yes yeah
you're not the police just remind
yourself that I also Advocate firearms
for police and you shouldn't just use
them at home willy-nilly I mean unless
you have a big home I don't
know so here's something else before we
get into everything that you've uh
you've already seen in the Run done
apparently women in relationships uh now
they need to go clubbing also mothers by
the way need to go clubbing with their
single friends uh otherwise they are not
being their authentic selves and we
wonder why relationships aren't working
and women are more unhappy than ever
this is our lukewarm take of the
week why would you need to go to a club
with just your girls you can say that
your partner is your best friend my best
friend I want to do everything if I go
to the store I'm like yo come tag along
with me CU they're not accepting you for
who you are and I think it does both
ways with women women are usually going
to the club by themselves and that's
what I was doing in that relationship is
I was going out with my friends because
I could act like myself and he always
tried to repress who I was and I was
like crazy girl and like having fun and
doing whatever I wanted and he would
always for it I think that's why people
go out separately because they want to
be themselves without being judged okay
ah I get it here here's the thing do
people expect there to be no changes or
sacrifices and relationships anymore
like I like going out with my friends
and I like drinking and just flirting
with a lot of guys what because I'm in a
relationship I don't get to do that
anymore
yes yes that's what it means by
relationship you don't get to do that
anymore y also here's the beauty too if
most people who grow up now if everyone
changed once they became mothers there
would be no crack baby so it's not lost
to me but a lot of people realize it's
so much more fulfilling to be home and
have their children and hey Mommy Daddy
right even watch a film with your kids
teach them something that that means a
whole lot more than going out and having
sex on the beach
shots but this this is me being my
authentic self well that's a bad self it
really is in being judged you should be
judged yeah I'm not saying that
somebody's like hey I'm better than you
it's like hey there's a lot of don't do
that you can go and have you can go and
have fun by the way with your
girlfriends but she said I'm going out
I'm the crazy girl I'm the fun girl at
the club which means you're probably
crazier crazier than the other single
women and that's a really bad sign
yes and she sounds like she was
referring to a previous boyfriend which
seems like that will be the case for a
very long time talking about the
previous boyfriend what do you guys
think Keith Kevin what if with a woman
who's like I look you I just I just you
know it's fine you stay home I'm going
to go out with my girlfriends I'm just
going to dance and I'll come home at
4:00 well I'll make the most of the
situation of course so I do all the
dirty naughty things I wouldn't do to my
real woman you mean you'd find another
woman she just she's just a for
you huh yeah that's what she is so
you're like can I just watch you're
sick sick human beings a sick thing to
do taking advantage of them women out
there you think this is a productive and
then men comment below if you would want
to be in a relationship like that here's
the thing men have not changed what they
want out of women in a relationship
women have changed what they want women
used to want to find a man right oh do I
have the ring that meant lock him down
right having monogamy right having
someone who can provide protect now men
want a woman who is nice who is
supportive who makes a house feel like a
home where they come home and go Safe
Haven guys let me know that's what men
want that's why billionaires marry
waitresses women now so I want to have a
guy so I want him to be or maybe they're
in an open relationship in which case
why be in an open relationship at all I
mean how many people are sleeping with
your wife Will Smith but let's go back
to traditional relationships here dang
where women now want so I want a man I
want him to be ready to provide protect
and serve for me and then I want to be
able to go out and do all the things
that I also enjoyed when I was single
and I want him to be strong I want him
to be masculine but I also want him to
be sensitive but not too sensitive and I
want them to pay for everything even
though I want to have equal rights on
every single front also um I like to
around a little bit a little bit
that seems like what she said by the way
this girl the types of I'm just guessing
on the types of guys that she's going to
bring in um is it okay if those guys
continue to go out and have guys nights
where they go out and find random girls
to hook up with and just kind of sleep
around and never do anything around
their house it's probably kind of a mess
because they really don't spend a whole
lot of time they're drunk most of the
time can they do that and not pay any
attention to you at all so that you can
go out clubbing with your girlfriends
because that seems like that would be
the fair way to go because you don't
want to judge him for being him right
now these guys are douchebags don't get
me wrong but you're a yes
they're I think it matters that's very
important we don't need to SC over that
look douchebag okay yes yes yes yes yeah
douchebag mhm
or
douchebag now douchebag just
want to make sure you're paying
attention that's what we used to call
them we used to call them
cads it's a sad State of Affairs here's
where we are 40% of young men will not
get married ever and now women in their
30s I think it's about 60% are saying
there are no men out there worth
marrying well because they don't want to
marry that look find a compromise this
is what we're talking about the self
love there's a compromise here of course
go out with your girl friends of course
go out with your guy friends that's fine
go even if your guys want to go out to
the pub have a drink have a sandwich
Watch the watch a sports game whatever
it is that you watch the sports ball you
want to go out with your girlfriends go
to a movie have a girl fine but not if
that's your identity that identity
cannot be reconciled with that of a
mother and a wife just like the identity
of a man who wants to go out and sleep
with every single person who he can find
at the does it's not something that is
Comm rent with being a father and a
husband that's it it's that simple the
problem is men are still punished if
they go out and live out their their
their worst base instincts and women are
praised for it there's nothing
praiseworthy there that woman watching
it goes back to the open you shouldn't
love yourself you have a lot of things
about yourself that you should
dislike because everyone else does we do
good
all right wh on that note Diane
Feinstein
oh last Friday uh of course passed away
at the age of age of 90 another one
taken too soon now we rarely take it too
soon this is a woman who was well known
she was well known for she breaking the
glass ceiling with her face that uh
brings us even though we didn't agree
with her of course uh we want to honor
her it's this week's time to close we
are aligned with with Feinstein and her
office sounds like you hope you don't
have to make another no I don't want to
make another appointment I don't think
the people of California want me to make
another appointment I both seats yeah
breaking news Democratic senator Diane
Feinstein of California has passed away
time to
close endings and Beginnings are ending
and beginning Now relationships matter
and I deeply believe that so if any of
you you must know China have ideas I
would certainly welcome them first
Politico revealed that a Feinstein
staffer was a Chinese spy you come in
here and you say it has to be my way or
the highway I don't respond to that I
think that she could have been a little
more respectful in how she communicated
with us here's what she had to say about
the city where she was born and raised
this is the CP capital of the United
States I just got punched in the face
right now by some guy that was pissing
on the street I can't believe I live in
a city where people can just the street
and come punch you in the face and get
away with it yeah just say I okay
just thank
you I know that it's time for things to
close I know that it's time for things
to
[Music]
close
[Laughter]
we need to pour out some Sherry for our
homies um oh
man
Pepto here's the thing too 90 look she
had a good run exactly that's what I
said the other day I was like I I just
don't feel bad when really old I don't
feel as bad let me say it that way when
really old people die I always feel bad
when people die right you know except
for Hitler but then not only except for
Hitler I didn't feel bad when B Laden
died I didn't either
hamler yeah there a lot of
people had a 90 year run I'm like well
they weren't taking too soon yeah
exactly also 90 years old you shouldn't
be in charge of decisions that affect
the rest of us in our tax dollars look I
had someone in my family I had a
relative who made it to 94 okay yeah and
I remember we were saying man at like 90
she was still pretty sharp like she
would play Beach Vol what we really mean
is you know she'd sit in a chair and
she'd kind of like H hit it but but we
thought that was really good like she's
really sharp she still does crossword
puzzles that's not voting on a bill she
can't drive you can't vote on a bill
where else think about the UAW right now
the strike of course they want 30 hour
work week for 40 hours of pay imagine
putting a 90-year-old on that factory
line put her in put her in HR no there's
no other place that someone like this
could do a job like that this is the
only place is the hellow halls of
government fire them once they reach the
age of
dementia it's different for everyone
simple enough there's nowhere else where
former Vice President Joe Biden would be
employed nowhere he's making everybody
else look good though these people these
people would be passed the cut off for
Walmart greeter okay yeah yeah yeah
anyway there's good news though Keith
and Kevin there's good news this morning
Gavin Newsome announced that fste sign's
replacement uh in the Senate is going to
be don't say it by the way no we had
them it's her name we have to say it we
did and we researched it just because
you don't want to we don't want to look
it's important cultural differences lefa
Butler now which also lefa Butler in
means nothing it's a madeup name there
is leanza means nothing it's something
that African amans black Americans make
up and actually has no meeting you guys
can fact check me on that below they're
great at making up
names they be butchered American name
one of them one of them forgot how to
the name of they were watching Happy
Days like I like that one with the
leather jack what's the with the one who
hits the Jukebox Le leans the fans Leons
that's your name
I don't like shut up that's your
name oh no he did Black
voice
cancel I dare you
you
so lefa Butler has many qualifications
though for this role will fill um those
wrinkly I thought you K that's her name
really Le no that's for real that's her
name that's her name Jes black people
Butler we have a clip of her too yeah
well wait wait do I you you went past it
did I go past it oh that's okay you know
what here's a clip of lefon Butler time
and again we have been told what choices
we can and cannot make we have come
together across race and across place to
respond to questions about our rights
with Clarity and resolve mhm Clarity and
resolve okay good that's very nice so uh
Jesus here are qualifications for the
role uh she's black there you go that's
a big one she's a lesbian that's that's
that's just that is a qualifier and
she's a president of Emily's List a
pro-abortion organization by the way
Emily's uh list their own website said
that Butler in case you didn't know that
the game was rigged she resided in
Maryland 19 days ago and now appointed
California Senator at least at least
Hillary Clinton did it for like a few
months yes it must be hard trying to
find a black woman yeah it is apparently
well and look the reason we said that
was one of the qualifications is because
Gavin Newsome promised that he would
appoint a black person to this role yes
without qualification and that's okay
you mean and so he had he had to racist
he had to Stretch Armstrong all the way
to Maryland get over here good f one in
California yeah pro-abortion black
lesbian in California ner one to pick
from yes exactly just not a good one and
by the way I don't even think they have
a great one lafonza Butler so we're
going to learn more about her but
there's not that much to learn bet you
Donald Trump now see at least if Donald
Trump presented it he would be like
she's a lesbian folks we haven't had a
black
lesbian got us another lesbian not one
of those ugly lesbians not one of those
ugly she's she she loves to scissor more
like shears shears this one like shears
you're using a
lamb she's black that's a thing black is
a thing nothing wrong with it a lot of
people like it they
say so hit the like like button if
you're going to enjoy watching
California destroy itself with people
from Maryland oh
man and this is a live show Monday
through Friday at 10 a.m. eastern you
can watch of course on rumble or the
audio anywhere podcasts exist and all
the mug club shows by the way have free
portions on Rumble and on uh apple and
Spotify so it's it's the same model you
get bunch of stuff free and then you
also get the full show the 100% as
opposed to 50% when you sign up at mug
Club you said you have a clip now Donald
Trump so Donald Trump actually right now
is in court over the Civil fraud Tri and
I think it's in New York and so he had
some Choice words uh for the New York uh
da all right so that's all right we have
a racist attorney general who's a horror
show who ran on the basis that she was
going to get Trump before she even knew
anything about me racist da who's a
horror
show that's the person inditing you
Donald
careful well look she may be in dating
me but she's a she's a creep is what she
is Creep Show I used to watched that at
night also alvara great tits on
alvara lesbian 2o also a scissoring
lesbian alvir found out later was very
dis people told me that I didn't want to
believe him folks somebody said they
have a lot of good people playing for
their team those lesbians
alvir an H Melissa eich come to my
window she said but she was with a woman
all
right now talking to yeah so this is
moments ago in the courtroom right here
you can see that go and bring It Up full
screen put us small screen Tim upside
down eggplant head commentator right now
look at the camera who's who's on the
camera Stevie Wonder like the moving
around so basically I think the hey do
my closeup Michael J fox
okay so basically the judge said that
there can't be cameras in there for the
opening statement but the judge did
allow the camera in there beforehand and
the camera's zooming in on the judge and
somebody's walking around and then it
goes onto the floor and they let it like
I'm I'm it's just stupid really this is
just all theater this being the news is
theater who is who is running this
camera I'm telling you if they go to the
judge it's even more funny because they
go from the judge literally p is the is
it the DP from Cloverfield yeah one
camera no tripod that's all you get but
there is an attractive woman next to
Donald Trump because I think it's a rule
he can't be seen without
exactly radius it's the anti-id rule
here's the thing though I will say uh I
love that he's having this out in the yo
careful this person's going after guess
what this person was Target no but this
person tting Donald Trump no matter what
and you will have lawyers and you will
have advisers tell you no no keep it
quiet hope that they move on from this
and then you know move on to the next
thing right move on to something else
the negative news cycle will go not when
they've targeted you and it's a smear
campaign where their only goal is to
Target you if it's sort of if it's
something that's temporary where they
think they can damage you which will
damage some kind of goal or damage some
kind of specific legislative
accomplishment like we saw that with
Matt gates at one point uh Matt GS
however we pronoun I always get it semi
so I said it right you got it right
people corrected me in the in the in the
chat and they said it's gats gats Like
Bernie Gets By the way loved his Subway
work
now Trump's attorney is smiling a whole
time I love being on camera you play
look I'll play bad cop you play
cop just never stop smiling so I can
look serious that's right La why is that
guy smirking I don't know he this
is crazy I love that he's going to have
it out in the open that is one thing he
you can tell that he made the conscious
decision from the get go all right we I
am going to ensure that this takes place
in the light the entire time why so that
you know every detail and he can
reference it that's important because
they maybe ding you with something that
you don't respond to people don't
remember and they think that that was oh
that must have been legit that must have
been legitimate because Donald Trump
didn't respond to it right you either
respond to everything or you hold and
then respond to everything or you have
to do the clam up and stay silent and I
don't think it'll work because if you
stay silent they're going after you
anyway yeah does anyone doubt this
whether you're a trump person or not
they're going to go after him no matter
what he does and that will happen with
any person with an R next to their name
who happens to be effective I don't care
who you are I don't care who you are and
that's why I say here with mug I don't
care unless you're a rapist murderer
pickpocket doesn't matter to me I don't
I don't I don't believe anything that I
read anymore and very little very little
of what I hear or see what do you what
do you think about Megan Markle this
will make sense I don't second you don't
you believe everything you hear well oh
yeah she's not running I I read that is
it is she actually is that it confirmed
it's not confirmed she is considering it
though well I seen that on Twitter and I
had heard that it wasn't true
considering running for running if it's
not true then we get to admonish the
researchers for putting I don't believe
that that's true driil in my hands well
Gavin Nome already has a list of people
she wasn't on the list and she hasn't
express any kind of a comment so this
would be a scoop if someone has it but I
don't necessarily know that it's true
also you know I prefer my
representatives to not be sociopaths but
that's a tall ask these days so she
would fit right in yeah she's married to
a she's married to a man who's trying to
blink Morse code with his eyes help me I
won
out I
out I went to better a prince I woke up
I woke up at pool
boy so Saturday night Joe Biden signed a
funding bill right that will keep the
government open oh thank god Till uh mid
November we always have this the
government shut down debt ceiling
because we never want to focus on the
fact that we have a spending problem
what was the last time that we actually
reduced spending by a significant amount
no no no yeah not cut the growth of
spending which is what we always do
right actually cutting spending like
actually reduce it by let's say one
percentage point or a dollar go with
dollar reduce it by $1 let's prices
right this reduce it by
$1 just a dollar so now there's this
focus on uh Democrat socialist
representative Jamal Bowman I'm
accidentally going to call him Brown for
some reason during this by forgive me
Brown technically but I'm just saying I
don't know why in my head it comes out
Jamal brown but Jamal Bowman so here's
why he pulled a fire
alarm while the Democrats were trying to
delay the vote on the spending bill so
they could blame it uh on Republicans so
this is you know there are a lot of
tactics that they use out there on
Capitol Hill this is not Chief amongst
them but every now and then uh you know
you have to commit a gross safety
violation and just before the house was
scheduled to vote on that funding bill
New York congressman Jamal Bowman pulled
a fire alarm inside the Cannon House
Office Building this photo has just been
released by US capital police
Congressman Bowman told reporters he was
trying to get through a door and thought
the alarm would open that doorperson
says it was an accident and that the
congressman regrets any confusion some
Republicans in the house want Bowman
censured for his actions Capitol Police
say they are investigating oh they're
investigating really it seems pretty cut
we actually have the exclusive footage
of the internal investigation now can
you zoom in right there what do you
think this is Monday Night Football best
I can do is
50% what do you think Rolex uh-uh it's a
tag height say about 510 yeah say so and
he's
black by the way Exit Wounds was written
by a four-year-old just to be clear
alert I I I just love Yeah he was going
he was trying to open the door so he
pulled this alarm and it was confusing
uh of course that that that that
obviously that dog won't hunt it's
really undeniable at this point we've
done it in the past but we need to
revisit this because so much has
happened this is time for uh this week's
installment of Jamal Bowman what a piece
of
[Music]
now he did defend himself I don't
know if he guys saw he said I want to be
very clear this was not me in any way
trying to delay the
vote now here's the thing that's right
away seems like protesting too much but
then he goes on to say it was the exact
opposite hold on a second so it was the
opposite so you were trying to really
really
vote he thought that was a lever yeah I
was trying urgently to get to a vote
which I ultimately did all right come on
now wow jeez now to be in his defense
there were early reports that he did
indeed smell
smoke I think that I think that there
was a reason that they did it tool man
all right never mind oh jeez
Tim oh makes sense fired admonish
yourself admonish yourself Tim come on
you that one was that one was timing
Reliant it
was and he was slow to admonish
himself all three of them very
everything he's very white it's all type
type one fibers
I just I don't know why I this does not
mean any way trying to delay the vote it
was the exact opposite of that I was
trying really really hard he sir sir are
you stealing from this Walgreens no I
wasn't I'm not stealing from this
Walgreens it looks like you have
$994,000 and buy it again why how do you
buy your
Pharmaceuticals sir that makes no sense
are you a racist all right just steal
the it's the dumbest argument I've
ever heard I pulled a fire alarm because
I didn't know how to work a door that
has a sign on it that explains how to
work the door by the way I did this once
I did this once I was supposed to show
up to this you did it on purpose it was
a holiday exhibit where I was taking my
little ones show up it was at the wrong
it was at the wrong location and instead
I showed up to like some blog con thing
some guy walking around in latex and
like anime and at this point I could see
uh my children like looking like this is
weird and I just said I just got to get
out of here alert alert so I could open
the door and get
out just took the fire
exit so uh Bowman's fellow socialist uh
and I say this because self-described
his fellow socialist representative AOC
who by the way does look like she has an
eye trainer so she's looking good here
uh defended Bowen on CNN he says it was
an accident he thought pulling the alarm
would open a door uh based on the fact
that the doors to his right there were
locked and there was a sign that he said
he was I think someone said it was
confusing I'll be honest that doesn't
really make sense to me his explanation
have you talked to
him what's going on there I mean listen
I think if you actually do see some of
the photos of the signs I think there's
there's something to be said about the
government's about to shut down there's
a clock that's going down you have a
really ex that are normally open in that
building were suddenly closed he you
pull the fire alarm
so Jake Tapper ladies and gentlemen does
buy it now to be fair again in his
defense here is the sign that AOC was
talking about that could be confusing
okay yeah that's understandable it makes
sense now before we get fact checked
here's the actual picture of the sign
which by the way is just as absurd it's
very clear emergency exit only emergency
it says fire pull that back up you know
what that thing on the right doesn't say
pull to open the door no no it does not
signs on the door but this is they've
got they've got a tunnel underneath the
ground I talked to Sam they can actually
go out doors that are down to the left
there's plenty of open doors he knew
exactly where he was going and what he
was doing and he's an idiot to be fair
the doors are usually open and they were
all slam shut At Once by a poltergeist
perhaps there were Dementors in the
building and so he was very confused uh
and I you know it could you know what it
could have just as easily been any of us
it wouldn't have been any of us it
actually it could have been you it
wouldn't have been me I would have known
how to use it could you know what who's
to say I'm to say this is horeshit
did the fan show up of course not maybe
they did I have no idea the point is the
now here's the thing not everyone is
convinced including president Trump who
wrote this I just on Truth social was
fantastic he
goes will Congressman Jamal Bowman be
prosecuted and imprisoned for
dangerously for very dangerously pulling
and setting off the main fire alarm
system in order to stop a Congressional
vote that was going on in DC his
egregious Act is covered on tape a
horrible dis display of nerve and
criminality it was very and I love how
he puts this like it's a title of a film
right in quotes he goes it was a very
dangerous obstruction of an official
proceeding also my favorite cigar film
that was the words I was looking for
earlier the same is used against our j6
prisoners actually his act may have been
worse some might say I would never say
that people tell me it may have been
worse they say I say Really they say
yeah he must suffer all cap he must
suffer their same fate when will his
trial
begin now here's the thing this is a
horrible human being Bowman okay his
Shenanigans go Way Beyond pulling of
fire alarms because once in a blue moon
now last March this is the guy in case
you've forgotten him he gotten in I
don't want to say got into a
confrontation he verbally assaulted
representative Thomas Massie over school
shootings of course with all of his
facts wrong but again this was the fake
tough guy act this is the guy a lot of
people didn't know it's the same person
freaking cowards they're gutless they're
not here I'm talking about gun violence
you know there's never been I'm talking
about gun vience in a school that allows
teachers to carry carry guns you think
more guns Le to More Death more guns
lead to more death well then get them
out of the capital
building any
data you're carrying the water for the
gun lobby she just walks in between
them all right that's enough got now to
be fair again his defense he confronted
Massie in Barney Frank Hall and this was
the sign there that day so yeah
it's he's if nothing else he respects
the signs yeah right yeah he respects
the
signs you know that guy's um elected his
uh disc is the poorest in the country
really it's that's how he got that he's
bunch of idiots live there well just
because you're poor doesn't mean you're
stupid here's what I oh yes it does
in America it does so before being
elected uh in uh New York his he founded
the Cornerstone Academy for Social
Action in 2009 okay uhhuh now this is
you know an academy uh it sounds it
sounds very studious yeah academy uh
majority of the school students can't
read or do
math perfect so as far as his Academy
that he founded right and this is the
thing this is a stepping stone oh look I
I I did some Community uh Community
organizing I contributed to community I
created the Cornerstone Academy for
Social Action okay 24% of people at the
Academy that he founded were capable of
executing math at their grade level 35%
of the students were capable of reading
at a grade level I know what you're
thinking well did they bring those
numbers up from you know what at this
point it doesn't matter it's it's it's
it's a third and a quarter of your
students can do basic math and
reading if nothing else can we say hey
it hasn't worked hey you screwed those
you screwed those kids academically you
left them behind now he's also
introduced bills to in case you haven't
uh case case you don't have this in your
memory bank all references are available
at
l.com tax money that you haven't even
earned
yet tax quote unquote excess profits
which is never really fully clearly
defined and then uh he wanted to
designate August 2023 as official hip
hop recognition month I'm okay with that
one I really don't have too much of a
problem with it well what y expect his
name is
Jamal it's got three A's in
it that's
Jamal Jal that's it J
Mo this is change this is also a guy to
go to your point he's advocated
defunding the police worked like a charm
he wants to bring the green New Deal to
Public Schools I don't even know what
that means uh it's a $ 1.6 trillion doll
initiative that's what it means but to
bring it to bring it to Public
Schools what does that what does that
mean you're going to put solar panels on
there for the grass on the roof I know
newal for schools hey yes more weed for
the students I love how he's like he's
sitting there like hey only 34% of
people from your Academy and 20 are
capable of math and 24% sorry 24% are
capable of math only 34% are capable of
reading it's like yeah we need wind
turbines that's right we like focus on
literacy and yeah Greenery nope Urban
farming that is crazy 34% of students
can read yeah 34% can read at their
grade level so he Advocates also by the
way he's a huge advocate of uh this is
just really annoying I guess but again
this is a what a piece segment
Green Transportation here's a
clip peace y'all we're leaving for
August recess take it easy
one hey that's my bike that's my bike he
stole
it he crossing the street not even look
where he's going freaking
idiot he didn't even look he like hey
peace one look where he's going fin
destination his not most egregious but
dumbest uh he wanted to have the New
York Jets bring Colin Kaepernick back in
bringing Colin
Kaepernick man save the
season peace yeah because that's what
he's known for is saving the season he's
been out of the leag for I don't know
four or five years and he sucked when he
was in it last so yeah he's gonna help
this is a guy everything is fake
everything about him is fake bring back
Kaepernick save the season no one's ever
said oh my God we're behind we need to
save this franchise there's only one
call to
make bring in the
cap Who the Cap who are you talking
Colin Kaepernick BR Colin Kaepernick you
mean that mediocre who yeah yeah yeah
well you know he'll kneel and we'll get
it'll be a whole thing I have a whole
thing it'll be
nice that bring in Kaepernick green look
at me on my bike hey Green Schools when
the things that matter like the students
being able to read or execute math it
doesn't take priority hey actually
voting no it's I want to Grand stand and
say look that look at Republican
shutting down the government while he
pulls the fire exit and storms out the
back and
also that was redundant and also also
he's a stupid person what did you think
you thought there wasn't going to be a
camera of you pulling the fire alarm
it's right there every
day worse worse I'll I'll be okay cuz
I'll just say it was an accident I was
trying to get out of the doors yeah was
confused and then his excuses I'll say
that the sign was confusing which is
also on camera
sir you have the same reading
proficiency as your
school what a piece of the I just
think I watch this I'm like wait hold on
a second because this is all Grand sary
the government it's really going to
affect federal workers and I'm sorry I
we we could trim that back anyways it's
a little bit bloated maybe some parks
will be shut down this idea that your
life is going to come to an end if the
government doesn't increase it's
spending by another whatever trillion
dollars I'm sorry I don't buy into it
this is the definition of political
theater but for a guy like this to try
and Grant and look Republicans are
shutting down the government all right
you know the vote's going to be in can't
hear
you everything is fake it's a show and
this is why this is how you want to end
up with populism you want to end up with
angry violent PE people a population
yeah that all of a sudden decides all
right you know what we're just going to
we're just going to have a coup I'm not
advocating you want to know this is how
you do it this is how you do it when you
have people whove accomplished nothing
who've actually hurt their local
communities and simply want to raise
some money being a talking head on a
Cable News Network that nobody watches
anymore and so they commit at the very
at the very least gross safety
violations most likely serious crimes or
minor felonies and that's why we just
needed to revisit this like if you agree
that Bowman is a
giant piece of
[Music]
all right you said do you want to
explain the bill or do I want to go to
the Nobel Prize uh we can do whichever
one you would like to do all right hold
on let me see what we have here the pill
you know what you guys know about the
bill who really
cares you guys know Gates doesn't like
McCarthy I don't like McCarthy you know
okay I'll just I'll just tell you this
about the it doesn't really matter that
much look we're going to increase
spending Republicans are going to make a
show of it not a whole lot's going to
happen the Republicans want to fund
Ukraine anyway they've several of them
have said that that's their number one
priority you understand that so
government will continue to exist uh
poorly and you will foot the bill and
this is going to happen in another
depending nine months time one year's
time depending on the interval well so
there's some interesting things that
have happened so Gates does want
McCarthy out so let's play that let's
play the clip of first off mcarthy did
say like hey anyone who wants to
challenge me you can hey come on and
bring it so was feeling bold this
day you know what if somebody wants to
remove because I want to be the adult in
the room go ahead and try this was
yesterday that was
yesterday and then Florida
representative Matt GS said say no
more I do intend to file a motion to
vacate against speaker McCarthy this
week I think we need to rip off the
Band-Aid I think we need to move on with
new leadership that can be trustworthy
look the one thing everybody has in
common is that nobody trusts Kevin
McCarthy he lied to Biden he lied to
house conservatives he had appropriators
marking to a different number altogether
and the reason we were backed up against
the shutdown politics is not a bug of
the system it's a feature I mostly like
Matt Gates but he does look like a
Kennedy twin who ate the other twin and
was the only one who came
out he he may have overplayed his hand
here a little bit not not a lot of
people like speaker McCarthy but it
looks like the GOP is looking to expel
Mt Gates oh and quote no one can stand
him yeah but guess what that's coming
from people who I can't stand no no no I
understand that I'm not saying yeah
exactly I I don't I'm just saying like
this could get ugly for him yeah good
not good for him but good that he's
willing to do it I agree people always
ask me hey what do you think about
karthy like I don't I don't really think
about him I think he's pretty much an
empty suit I think most of these people
are there are a few exceptions you know
someone who's an exception to this is
Rand Paul guess who very few people like
Rand Paul yeah no I don't so here's my
thing I hope he has his ducks in a row I
hope he didn't just go out and say some
stuff like last time when he wouldn't
vote for McCarthy and then somebody came
and literally leaned in and spoke very
harshly to him and then he voted for
McCarthy I need to make sure like if
you're going to go after this guy with
that nobody likes make sure that you can
get the job done don't just go out there
and throw stuff out hoping right for you
know theater that you're going to get
some votes out of it that's what every
government thing the Deb ceiling rate
all of this stuff it's just absolutely
silly you know what comment below if
you'd like to see McCarthy removed his
speaker uh and if you would rather see
someone like a Matt Gates and here's no
one is perfect just to be clear but I've
never worshiped politicians and I think
that we've gotten to this point of I
unfortunately on the conservative side
look there's U an unbelievable amount of
nonprofit influence who also bump rub
shoulders I guess I should say with uh
with with GOP politicians I don't like
it a lot of these other conservative out
they're running Charities 501 c3s 501
C4s we run a business and so we'll often
get from even people who we've covered
today sometimes right saying hey we want
to come on the show but we want these
talking points you have to change the
studio and we go no we're not going to
do that we're not going to have you on
to sell your book they think that these
programs because they largely do in the
conservative space exist to push their
next campaign as opposed to these
programs exist to be a platform where
they can answer to you the people and I
think that's perverse I think it's
actually an inverse uh of of of what we
should have there's an inverse
correlation between being a non uh uh a
non- piece of in being a politician
not that all of them are but as a
general rule that's kind of what we see
so I I'm not a big fan of any of them
the starting off point is let's see what
you do haven't been impressed with
McCarthy Matt Gates sometimes I noticed
a lot of the scandals that were attached
to him went away yeah because they were
all Bs they were all Bs yeah but
everybody believed them everybody
reported did you see them do retractions
no here's the thing not every not
everybody believed them that's it's even
worse than that a lot of people knew
that they weren't real right yeah
general public people on the
conservative side right oh they did and
they didn't come to bad for him it's
weird when that happened yep y all right
let's go to the Nobel Prize for the MRNA
injection because that's also a fun
topic so the Nobel Prize in physiology
now just to be clear I don't know if you
guys know a lot about the Nobel Prize um
it's now with the Nobel Prize when
people someone says hey I got a Nobel
Prize it's kind of like saying I got a
free toy in my Happy Meal it doesn't
really okay thought it was something
prestigious yeah Special no mm- so uh
the prize for physiology has been
awarded to to United States base
research ERS for their research and
their work on the MRNA
vaccine the Nobel assembly at Carolin
Institute that has today decided to
award the 2023 Nobel Prize in physiology
or medicine jointly to Cataline carico
and Drew Weissman for their discoveries
concerning nucleoside base
modifications that enabled the
development of effective Mr R vaccines
against coid 19 always a good call to
have it delivered by a bond
villain Jesus the vaccine it wears off
after six months it doesn't give you
immunity these these globalists don't
even try and hide it anymore no like hey
who should we have because people are
kind of onto our game here where it
almost seems like we're elitist and
Sinister who should we hand out here to
to to present this prize I don't know
I'm thinking like a Kristoff Waltz meets
uh those creatures from The Descent type
I'm so excited for this
vaccine it's more like a
reward now the prize by the way uh for
this uh totally safe and completely
effective vaccine is $1 million Y which
we'll get to the math is very small
potatoes compared to what you paid to
develop the vaccine anyone get their
check yet you get your check yet you
didn't get your check yet so record
profits for the record profits for the
the pharmaceutical companies but you
didn't no one here got their check now
I'm still it must be lost in the
government shutdown Ah that's yeah so
when you're talking about the vaccine
and the research and what's come to
fruition here's a look at some of their
best
[Music]
work
he that was me this is his tweet right
and I I put it in one of the channels I
think Sam has it or somebody has it we
can pull it up in a minute but he goes
what they did is actually did X which
did this to it which made all the spike
proteins available which is what is
causing all of the problems they just
got an award for screwing up my
invention right that's what he tweeted
out it was really funny Robert Malone
Robert Robert Malone kind like Ben
Affleck getting a screenwriting award
yeah Goodwill Hunter it's pretty
accurate so I know what you're saying
that video is anecdotal okay granted and
we'll get some key facts here because we
always have to be careful when we're on
uh YouTube because I think now they
allow you to question vac you can
question election results I know that
because Hillary Clinton already notice
this remember when this happened you
know what someone should pull this from
back uh when they announced that you
could question election results on that
show I said I guarantee you they're
preparing to do the Russia Russia Russ
Russia thing because that's what's going
to happen in the next election now we
see Hillary Clinton preparing saying oh
Putin's going to try and medal with this
election well because there's a there's
a 27o spread between the Rec poll and
Donald Trump how he was performing in
the last election if the election were
held today it would be an absolute
Landslide it wouldn't even be close
probably for any Republican but
certainly Donald Trump it would not be
close just to be clear and so they're
getting ready to question the election
results so now you're allowed to and I
think it's the same thing now with with
Co and the vaccine which makes me think
they're probably going to look to try
and pin the negative effects of the coid
vaccine and operation warps speed and
Donald Trump so course yeah I know
you're saying that video was anecdotal
okay but here's something that's not
here's something that is not empirical
but historical we're talking about the
Nobel Prize winners uh these people join
other luminaries such as Fritz Fritz
habber who developed chlorine gas oh won
a prize Antonio igas mon the labotomy
inventor so that's a wonderful one and
then uh yaser aaat terrorist an Al Gore
professional Swedish massage Enthusiast
and he won a prize for An Inconvenient
Truth which a British High Court ruled
had nine significant errors well just
nine I thought we were supposed to be
dead by now
yeah yeah Florida is supposed to be gone
for sure yeah according to An
Inconvenient Truth they got a Peace
Prize
though not to be outdone former
president Barack Obama got the Peace
Prize eight months into his first term
for quote extraordinary efforts to
strengthen International diplomacy and
cooperation between uh peoples and so I
think this was like a preemptive it was
like a Minority Report Peace Prize they
gave to him for things he hadn't done
yet and then he used the Peace Prize the
award to uh go on to effectively bring
World Peace Time Magazine says an
American drone strike hit a wedding
Convoy yesterday in Yemen at least 13
people were reportedly killed initial
Reports say suspected militants were
thought to be traveling with the group
but civilians may have been mistakenly
targeted a red line for us is we start
seeing a whole bunch of chemical weapons
moving around or being utilized first of
all I didn't set a red line oh boy the
world said a red line
everything no no no no now what I said
was I was I was on an airplane watching
The Thin Red Line different
movie and I like the film but it wasn't
as good as having Private Ryan but
people took that to me and I said red
line I didn't say red line that there's
a blue
line sometimes a green line but not no
that's a
Subway everything about that man is fake
look you can say whatever you want about
remember when he said like my you know
my mom always used to say uh don't get
all wee weed up and people like that's
not a thing ah they say where I'm from
no they don't they do
Kenya oh sorry he said where he's
from by the way the th the red line
thing this wasn't some trivial thing
this was when Assad was using chemical
weapons on his own people that was the
red line if he goes and uses chemical or
biological weapons that's the red line
where the us will have to get involved
and everyone's like that seems like a
pretty good red line if you use chemical
weapons on your own people yeah and then
he did
right so this is the thing is the Nobel
uh the Nobel Prize committee right this
is about propaganda uh just like when we
talk about this we talk about the uh uh
the wh um when we're talking about the
CDC we've talked about right I'm not
saying you should be anti-scientific in
the scientific method scientific method
is brilliant as a matter of fact that's
what we do with uh largely Chang my mind
what we do here is trying to apply the
scientific method right that that is
something that is of value um eternally
it never changes what I'm saying is
these institutions who have told you
that they're the only ones who can
effectively employ the scientific method
look right now hold on a second is there
the no the Nobel Prize committee is
there science that exists
today that 20 years from now when we
look back on this like the chlorine gas
guy or Yas or aaat is there scientist
are there scientists and is there
science today that suggests that the
MRNA injection is actually harmful that
this is not a good thing and certainly
not for children that's how you judge it
with fouchi and a where he said it could
be transmitted through cereal
boxes from a child from a parent to
their child if they lived in the same
duplex right was there science available
that said that was wrong people look
back and say oh we didn't know better
hold on a second did we know better when
coid after the first two weeks we did do
we know better than right now to give
these people these kinds of awards we
absolutely do which brings us again to
something how how does this affect you
so the Nobel Prize says these people
deserve Awards well first off what about
the
investor what about the investor This
research doesn't exist without
investment right these are worker bees
now we don't want to talk about that
because the investor is you I want you
to if if nothing else changes this month
I've been on I've been on this track
because it's important when people say
government that's you that's your money
the only thing that government can do is
take your money and give it to something
else you you purchased that you
purchased an F35 you paid for this
vaccine you you didn't didn't choose to
you were forced to that is your money
it's not McCarthy's money it's not
Pelosi's money it's not Biden's money
it's your money so when we're talking
about the M mRNA injection big Farmer
they raked in huge record profits right
from this coid vaccine which the re for
which the researchers were just awarded
a Nobel Prize you paid for
it fiser biontech and modna three
vaccine makers they delivered two shots
for the Wuhan virus do you know how much
profit they made from these shops on the
screen
$1,000 every second you heard that right
$1,000 every second fiza btech and Monna
made $1,000 every second from Wuhan
virus vaccines by the way I I love like
you said how she paused for dramatic
effect when it's on the lower currenc do
you know hey hey and look yes I bet you
run like so I'm going to ask and I'm
going to take dramatic pause do you know
how how much they made and her ear pie
like oh sorry underloaded just shut up
do you know one two 3
4 every
second uh it's not just on the the lower
third it was on the giant green screen
thing I don't know I don't know I'm a
performer it's actually larger than you
on the screen yes but it's dramatic
effect I'll do I'll do it will work so
I want to go through this this is going
to be uh kind of a recurring thema they
made and you paid so they made when
we're talking about these companies $90
billion wow in profits from the coid
vaccine that's a lot of here's the thing
it's not even done yet in 21 and 22
those are the numbers those are the
numbers from 21 to 22 yeah now I don't
care how much you make if you are M if
you are making money as an honest
business I don't no here's the problem
you
paid $30 billion
for development of the vaccine which by
the way is a tougher pill to swallow
that when you understand that you paid
for that when many of you were out of
work through mandate and all the while
fizer was lobbying for these vaccine
mandates also by the way kind of
surprising that they're one and the same
with the CDC with who who were lobbying
for lockdown S I think the who said they
actually weren't
helpful well but they didn't do anything
about that they didn't really do
anything they just like Ah that's not
when Italy locked down they're like we
don't think that's very helpful and then
two weeks later it's like hey we need to
lock the world down and this is why look
the libertarian thing is is is dead we
do not have a free enterprise system
it's not even close we have the worst
parts of socialism right now that that
really and socialism is is all bad but
to have privatized funding and then or
sorry I should say socialize losses
privatize fun they want to privatize
profits socialize losses or in this case
socialize the Investments then privatize
the
profits not only should you get your 30
billion back you should get a percent of
the profit for the rest of your life you
make it a part of Social Security and I
know the people say oh it won't actually
be that much it'll be a drop in the
bucket largely obviously because of
inflation but if we do that with every
single company that we bail out and we
fund hey hold on a second uh Airlines
have you gotten your check from American
Airlines from United how about the big
three auto makers how how about energy
companies that exist out there how about
the big Banks of course you getting your
check from bailing out any profits that
are generated after your bailout should
be paid back to you not to the
government into a slush fund to you the
taxpayer with interest so 90 billion
here I don't if we go through the banks
a few hundred billion there you add up
you'd have a few trillion dollars a year
in these profits that can be distributed
back to the PE just like investors like
shark like Shark Tank it's like Shark
Tank only for taxpayers and it should be
mandatory that's the issue so when
people often say hold on a second the
system is rigged and their solution is
socialism no no no the problem that we
have is the socializing of investment
and of losses and the privatizing uh
privatizing of profit
and yes that's where Donald Trump speaks
the language of these people where he
says the game is rigged and I get it he
probably used the game when he was in
New York I understand it but at least
he's willing to point it out these
people all use the game they all rig the
system at least he was saying hey these
people are rigging it against you how do
I know because I had to play ball with
them and while we're talking about the
vaccine I mean I'm surprised that it's
this profitable oh that's right the only
reason it's that profitable is through
government man
as well which you also fund but there
might be a
shutdown hey how about you just stop the
shutdown by taking all the money from
the company that we funded anyway piece
of so it's crazy man they forced us
to pay and everything and then forced us
to take it yeah forced us to pay and
they wanted to force us to take it and
then because they have egg on their face
let's give them a Nobel Prize here for
research well let me give you a few
stats that I think we're allowed to talk
about on YouTube if not then can hit the
YouTube dump button go and watch it on
Rumble myo cardus risk in V recipients
it's the highest in mes right ages 12 to
17 the excess deaths jumped 85% in 3
years
what I know it's high that's what I'm
saying it's it's unbelievable you should
just smile and blow me I I
deserve
it I don't know why we have we have a
racist what 85% from 2019 to 21 uh is
the excess deaths that jumped okay vs
they have 171 th Americans who reported
adverse effects in 2021 by the way they
stopped counting the government demanded
that they they scale that back just to
be clear they're far more than that so
from the Nobel committee to the big
pharmaceutical Industries and your
government they're basically one and the
same no one has your best interest at
heart it is your responsibility to take
care of yourself but more importantly it
is your responsibility to be aware we so
often separate I don't know why we do
this it's the first thing
it's it's the first ground that we can't
concede I've served the people for no
you didn't you took money from the
people period Biden you've taken money
from the people for 50 years okay you
didn't Serve the People for 50 years
John Cary I serve the hold on a second
private jets that's from my private oh
that's from your Private Industry okay
Al Gore served the people the clintons
have served the people Barack Obama yes
he served the people the bushes served
the people to be clear they all want you
to believe that there's this I no no no
no no no anytime they say I I insured I
spent this m no you didn't spend
anything you took our money you took and
in this case it's really tough to
swallow because it's one of the biggest
mistakes in history this experimental
mRNA injection that you forced us to
fund and then you tried to force people
to take and even when it didn't work you
just said you know what more boosters
even when International govern I believe
it's is it the UK there are governments
in Europe who said we're not going to be
giving this injection to uh young people
to people I believe under the age of 16
the United States said hold my
beer we are further to the left of of
progressive European leftist nations in
a lot of ways certainly on the trans
issue and certainly on the bodly
autonomy issue it is it is kind of scary
to think about all from public servants
and what that really means is people who
take your
money there's no difference between
fouchi Joe Biden and the head of fizer
they receed their money from the same
place you and you get nothing for your
you get no return on your
investment I think it's that simple and
that's got to change you guys can
comment below don't allow any politician
Republican or Democrat to say I spent
they didn't spend
they take
it beautiful you about to say
something Gerald I was going to say too
they they they take they they got all
this money to fund it and then they
mandated it and then they told you you
couldn't Sue when there was an adverse
reaction as well and they're continuing
to fund it all of the boosters as well
right that's not that's not all being
funded by big Pharma and by the way
isn't it funny it's the Democrats
obviously who love this vaccinees like
they just love remember we showed that
Canadian clip like I'm just a walking
human
pinc and they were they were being they
weren't even being faci they were
actually being genuine it was like a
parody this video of these uh these
Canadian women in a on a was it a
Morning Show yeah but think about this
for a second these are the people who
wanted to push through Obamacare which
again didn't look out for you was the
biggest Kickback to the insurance
industry now the proposed solution from
people who are more libertarian and more
conservative was well hold on a second
okay let's look at allowing Insurance
across state lines to increase
competition tort reform to some degree
now I do think that you need to be able
to sue a doctor right if you I mean if
you if you go in lawsuits yes if you go
in with a toothache and you come out
with Bell's py you should be able to sue
right yeah can that happen I can really
I went in normal I came out like Justin
Bieber oh Bieber you should be able to
sue but the frivolous lawsuits like
professional ambulance Chaser uh you
know John Edwards um we suggested they
were adamantly against it the left until
it comes to the vaccine companies who by
the way these these giant corporations
who get 30 billion of your tax dollars
same thing of course we're against we're
against the big Banks we're against
these until Vanguard and black rock
they've bought up so many uh single
family units that you are not able to
afford uh a house um and they've been
deemed too big to fail by the Socialist
and chief Elizabeth Warren Chief poor
choice of words because is the least
Native American person ever let's
go with that yeah so but it's this is
the problem with those in government is
is is it's socialism really for thee but
not for me and not for these companies
Black Rock Vanguard just so you know the
reason that housing prices are
unaffordable has nothing to do with your
neighbor buying up houses has not
certainly in this economy right now has
nothing to do with the economy being so
rip roaring that there aren't enough
homes for people that's actually not
true the ratio of people to homes right
now is at a pretty good pretty healthy
level or it would be if these units
weren't being purchased by
multi-trillion Dollar companies who are
deemed too pigged to fail by the
government the reason that these
pharmaceutical companies are able to go
out and create these experimental
injections and do so consequence-free
it's because of you because they're
deemed too big to fail and they're only
able to do it through your
money probably didn't have $30 billion
lying around no they took it from you by
force and then they made you take the
shitty product by
force they take your houses by force by
coercion and then they make you pay to
bail out their company when the houses
eventually force their company to go
under through coercion at the end of the
day it's someone with a gun it's someone
at your door with a gun saying pay your
taxes that's the root problem of all of
this and then they have the nerve to
tell you that you shouldn't own a gun
well how are you going to make me pay my
taxes how are you going to make me pay
madna how are you going to make me pay
Black Rock how are you going to make me
pay for Chase for Bank of America how
are you going to make me pay for cindra
how are you going to make me pay for the
$130 million bonus for the CEO of
American Airlines how are you going to
make me pay for the big three the UAW to
get a 30h hour work week being paid 40
with the average hourly cost
$154 how are you gonna make me pay
someone's going to come to your house
with Guns by the way you don't get
guns it's not complicated it's pretty
simple we'll be discussing this and more
of course on if you're watching right
now on YouTube I have no idea if we're
still on YouTube uh you know go to
mugclub mug Club you just click the
button right now if you're on Rumble you
click that button below and you'll get
to continue watching seamlessly mug Club
you get this you get another full 45
minutes to hour of show it's like twice
the length of show Friday show Alex
Jones's Friday show Brian Ken show Nick
depalo Monday through Friday 5:00 P PM
uh Eastern is it Eastern or Central I
always get that messed up and we will be
announcing the Hodge twins tomorrow on
the network Mr guns and gear all of that
but we're going to actually go discuss
more hedge fund management oh no wait
that's right we're playing Arnold
Schwarzenegger character or hedge fund
manager Rumble thank you YouTube piss
off
[Applause]
a